le plaid vous permet
d'enseigner Estelle l'épinard fait
partie des 252 professeurs des écoles
stagiaires qui feront leur rentrée dans
les Yvelines le 4 septembre la jeune
femme fraîchement diplômée d'un Master
d'enseignements à étudier dans
l'académie de Bordeaux où elle a eu
l'occasion de participer à une
expérience pilote enseignée une journée
par semaine dans une vraie classe malgré
cette préparation elle appréhende la
prise en main de sa classe de CE2 à
Mantes-la-Jolie la semaine prochaine on
n'a pas été préparé à cela pendant les
stages puisqu'on arrivait en cours
d'année dans des classes qui avaient
déjà à mettre titulaire et un
fonctionnement en place donc ça ça va
être un peu plus nouveau donc oui c'est
la seule petite appréhension mais après
je reste confiante et je m'inquiète pas
pour l'aider à prendre ses fonctions le
plus sereinement possible Estelle a
participé pendant 5 jours à une période
d'accueil au lycée Sonia Delaunay de
Villepreux au programme présentation de
diverses problématiques auxquelles
devront faire face les enseignants les
problématiques qui vont rencontrer
durant carrière la scolarisation des
élèves handicapés les élèves en
difficulté les situations d'enfants pour
lesquelles nous sommes parfois obligés
de faire des signalements en direction
de la justice ou de la police pendant
leur année de stage les professeurs
seront accompagnés par un tuteur et un
maître compagnon il participeront
également à des regroupements durant
lesquels ils pourront aborder des
problèmes qu'il rencontre au quotidien à
la fin de l'année la plupart de ses
professeurs seront titularisés comme
l'ont été l'ensemble des stagiaires
yvelinois de l'année scolaire précédente